Chris Hardwick is the king of the
Nerdist Empire and AMC's many live after
shows he's hosted talking dead talking
bad talking Saul singled out an
@midnight among others but there's more
to him than that let's go beyond the
nerdy exterior and take a look at some
of the things you probably didn't know
about Chris Hardwick
bowling is in his blood he's a guy who
seems to have done just about everything
but one career he hasn't pursued
professional bowling sure most people
don't go into bowling as a real job but
Chris actually had pretty good reason to
consider it his parents met at a bowling
alley owned by his grandfather Chris's
father Billy Hardwick was a professional
bowler who want 18 Professional Bowlers
Association titles and was elected into
the PBA Hall of Fame in 1977 instead
Chris opted to strike it rich on
television and as no time to spare to
follow in his father's legacy he's a
legit philosopher Chris Hardwick has
built a career around his ability to
talk philosophically on just about any
nerdy topic under the Sun but unlike
most media pundits Hardwick is an actual
philosopher seriously he received a
degree in philosophy from UCLA where he
was a member of the Chive Phi fraternity
which has included members like
legendary news anchor Walter Cronkite
why philosophy Hardwick told the Chicago
Tribune it's perfect for comedy it
forces you to deconstruct he shared
quarters with Wesley Crusher if there's
anyone who carries the nerd flag as
proudly as Chris Hardwick it's Wil
Wheaton Wheaton is known for playing
Wesley Crusher on Star Trek The Next
Generation I know this meant finished me
as an acting ensign but shut up Wesley
with hosting duties on the web series
tabletop and appearing on the Big Bang
Theory Wheaton like Hardwick has made an
entire career and life out of being a
nerd amazingly enough the two geek icons
were actually roommates in college they
also met in an appropriately nerdy way
in line to see the 1990 horror comedy
arachnophobia MTV's singled out in the
early 90s Chris Hardwick got his big
break when he became a DJ at the
influential KROQ 106.7 in Pasadena
California Hardwick's radio popularity
brought him to the attention of Mt
II who hired him to co-host their dating
show singled out alongside Jenny
McCarthy taken to the Secret Garden
where all the other girls are buried the
rest is history
well sort of alcohol addiction after a
stint as host of MTV's singled out came
to an end
Hardwick life went into a tailspin due
to alcoholism he put on weight and found
himself in a personal and professional
rut finally he decided to kick alcohol
entirely and go sober which he speaks
openly about in his self-help memoir The
Nerdist way Hardwick comes clean I knew
that I had two choices I could continue
living the way I was living and die
pickled and unemployed or make sweeping
changes with the hope of salvaging my
life serial killers super villains and
The Terminator
while hard work is best known for
talking about TV shows and movies he
sometimes stars in them too
well depending on your definition of
star among his many acting credits are
minor roles in house of 1000 corpses
Terminator 3 rise of the machines and as
the voice of green arrow on the Batman
people are getting sick around here and
it's because of that dirtbag Bruce Wayne
he's even butted heads with handsome
jack as Vaughn and tales from the
borderlands but perhaps his greatest
role is Otis from back at the barnyard a
male cow with an inexplicable utter
that's not how cows work you guys
engaged to an heiress over the years
Hardwick has been linked to several
high-profile starlets including
actresses Jacinda Barrett and Jeanette
Barney in 2015 he finally became engaged
to one of the richest women in the world
Lydia Hearst an actress and fashion
model Lydia is the daughter of
infamously unwilling bank robber Patty
Hearst she's also on heir to the fortune
of her deceased great-grandfather the
legendary publishing magnate William
Randolph Hearst that's a whole lot of
comic books for Chris he's a serious
businessman being the world's
pre-eminent nerd isn't just a full-time
job it's also big business in 2008
Hardwick founded Nerdist three years
later Nerdist merged with geek chic
daily to form Nerdist industries and
later he became its chief creative
officer and when Nerdist industries was
purchased by legendary entertainment a
year later Hardwick was promoted to
co-president of their digital business
it just proves that you can't be the top
geek without having a serious helping of
smarts thanks for watching subscribe to
our YouTube channel to watch more videos
like the one you just saw and leave us a
comment to let us know what surprised
you most about Chris Hardwick